oh
hear me
yourself
and it seems to me you lived your life
but i was just
legendary
is
had
and it seems to me you lived your life
when the rain
something from the big version
you don't understand i understand well
you don't understand
and you never have understood is this
election gonna be a repeat of 2016.
i think so i think we'll do better than
2016.
we're way ahead of where we were in 2016
and i've done things that nobody's ever
done we built the greatest economy in
the world and we're building it rapidly
again
if you look at arizona you look at the
job they've done
and i'm just leaving other states that i
mean every one of these republican-run
states are doing phenomenally
the democrat-run states are not but
they're not going to affect our numbers
very much
i think they're going to open up on
november 4th they'll be opening up on
november 4th
and by the way the fact that kristen
welker
is you know a guide in the world
radical left democrat or whatever she is
okay
okay then ask why are you defending her
then ask her why did she delete her
account
would you please have her put her
account back and you know what it's not
going to affect i know you want to stick
up
it's not going to affect me i'm going to
be there but you know i told you about
the last one and i was right
and i told you about savannah guthrie
and i was right
and i'm telling you about kristen welker
kristen welker should put
all of her statements back on she
deleted her entire account she shouldn't
do that
i have no
uh idea doing this what am i doing to
prepare i'm doing this
i've done very well in debates and you
know you do what you do
you just do what you do the last debate
i had two on one i usually have two on
one at least
and i did well on the last debate and we
did well with savannah guthrie based on
reports
but all you can do is look you know you
go around we do interviews with you this
is like i call this
debate prep this is actually tougher
than a debate if you want to know the
truth
of the debate will you do the testing
before the debate and will you
yes the covenant and will you authorize
your doctors to tell us when
sure i would have no problem with it i'm
not only am i
free positive or whatever what would you
call it i'm totally free right
not only am i free i'm immune they say
they say if you've had it you're immune
now the question is are you immune for
four months or for the rest of your life
that's the only thing we don't know
you authorize your doctors to tell you
when you tested negative laughs before
sure is that very important to you you
seem to be so intent
but if it's so important to you why is
it so important to you because
yeah my doctors have already given it
you know my doctors have given more
information
than has been given on any human being
in the history of the world
strategy seems to be to paul biden a
criminal why is that he is a criminal
he's a criminal
he got caught read his laptop and you
know who's a criminal you're a criminal
for not reporting it
you are a criminal for not reporting it
let me tell you something
joe biden is a criminal and he's been a
criminal for a long time and you're a
criminal in the media for not reporting
it
good luck everybody have a good time
have a good time
um
that is
just before dawn through a silence
you feel you could cut with a knife
announces the cat
who can now be reborn and come back
to a different jellicle life
uh
memory turn your face
if you find there the meaning of what
happenness
is
i can smile at the old days
i was beautiful then
i remember a time i knew what
happened
smoking
a street lamp dies on another night
is
i must wait for the sunrise
i must think of a new life
and i mustn't give when the dawn
comes tonight will be a memory too
and a new day will
beginning
the trees in the sun
breaking the memory
is
if you touch me
you'll understand what happens
is
now
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
a regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
making love with tonic and gin
he says son can you play me a memory
i'm not really sure how it goes
but it's sad and it's sweet and i knew
it
when i worry under
sing us a song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me my drinks for free
and he's quick with a joke or to light
up your smoke
but there's some place that he'd rather
be
it says bill i believe this is killing
me
as a smile ran away from his face
well i'm sure that i could be a movie
star
if i could get out of this place
now paul is a real estate novelist
and he's talking with david who's still
in the navy
and probably will be
and the waitress is practicing politics
as a businessman slowly get stoned
yes they're sharing a drink they call
loveliness
but it's better than drinking alone
sing us the song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
it's a pretty good crowd for a saturday
and the manager gives me a smile
cause he knows that it's me they've been
coming to see
to forget about life
and the microphone smells like a beer
and they sit at the bar and
what are you doing here
a melody and you've got us
feeling all right
do
in
oh
can you feel it coming in
i
but i don't know who i am
another
oh
oh
first time
but i know the reason why
probably gonna start a
now it's time to leave
me
give me one good reason baby come on
me
i'm
i don't wanna be you
be
for you
our
foreign
foreign
free
this boy's too young today
you
foreign
oh
what do you think you do then
maybe
just like
my
oh
ow i got him can't do the bottom
get
what makes a man
but he came in he thinks mine and jay
said goodbye
hit me
a woman
me get down
make it good to yourself
make good baby
it makes me feel so good
alone
um
in the midnight
i see them
the lunatic is on the grass
on the grass
remember
the paper holds
the paper boy brings more
is
i'll see you on the dark side
is
you make the
you change me till i'm safe
you lock the door
throw away the key
yes someone in my head
starts
i'll see you on the dark side of the
moon
thank you
young man there's no need to feel
and i'm sure you will find many ways
you can get to something
what do you wanna be i'm
you can make real your dreams but you've
got
to know this for one thing
no man does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf
you can hang out with all the boys
you can do whatever
ymca they can't stop you
it's fun to stay at the high mca
it's fun to stay at the ncaa
is
pick yourself off the ground
let's go bye
there is
i would
potato
down
is
is
foreign
tell your children
not to do what i've
been doing
spend your life
misery in the house in sun
train
tape
and you are
i know
do
please please please
please
you did me wrong
oh
please
please
i
baby take my hand
i wanna be your father
i love your soul
peace
i've paid my dues
time after time
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've met a few
i've had my
my friends
we are the champions
but it's been no bed of roses
i consider it a challenge
my friends
we are
my friends
is
me
me
he's a macho man
hey i've got to be a macho
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th president
of the united states donald j
trump
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave
god
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to la
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
that i'm proud to be an american
and defend her still today
the men who died who gave
next to you and defend her still today
hello prescott hello prescott i better
speak fast the sun is hot
this sun is hot
so did anybody notice i'm sure you
didn't that we flew over right over you
right
we have the greatest pilots and the
greatest equipment anywhere in the world
i said i wonder if there'd be any danger
no sir
don't worry foia and then flying over i
noticed something right
i saw this crowd and then i saw a crowd
bigger than this over there trying to
get in can you believe it
let them in let them in let them in
they're coming in just let them in i
thought we could wait would you like to
wait about an hour as they peel
do you have speakers back there please
all right
you know the fake news they never report
this stuff right
right sleepy joe biden yesterday had
seven people and then they say he's tied
in the polls in pennsylvania
you know i don't know there's something
going on here there's something phony
going on
so you know the votes are coming in and
they're very much
uh inclined to be with us i don't know
if you see you know early voting
because our people like to go out like
and vote right they like to vote
they like to vote and uh it's incredible
what's happening so
the early votes are coming in in a lot
of areas and they're starting to get a
little bit nervous on the other side
in michigan we're leading the early vote
we're supposed to be at 20
and then we catch him right in the final
day it's like a rate source
no no no it's uh it's gonna be very big
you don't have events like this and you
come in second in arizona okay you don't
do that
you don't say i don't like
i don't like saying let's leave now
goodbye are you 25
40 000 whatever the hell number of
people goodbye everybody oh we're in
second place in arizona you know i don't
think so
now we're uh we're in first place in
arizona
but you know these fake people back here
the press the media they're fake
and same thing same thing happened last
time only worse it was crazy
and last time i never did it before so i
believed him and then what happened is
we had the day and
i was down in nine states
that i had a win right i was down in all
nine
on election day and we won all nine
right no they said
they said this will be a very poor day
for donald trump that time
donald trump right this is going to be a
rough day for donald trump down in ninth
states
end of the evening then you saw them cry
remember the guy with also john king
oh my god he just won wisconsin he's
just won
michigan he just won arizona
he just won pennsylvania what's going on
now they were not having a good day they
will not have this is going to be even
better i think
i mean the only difference is the one a
big risk is they
sent out tens of millions of these
unsolicited ballots
and we're trying to find out who do they
send them to when do they send them
where do they send them
who sends them back some of these
governors say you don't need cert
signature verification why would you
need a thing like that
no signature verification in some cases
you don't need a signature why would you
need a thing like that
no they found 50 000 in a river they
found
53 000 in a creek they found many in a
garbage can they happened to be from the
military
many of them they were in a garbage can
they found him
and they all had the name trump on isn't
that shocking they were military all in
favor of trump
and they found him in a garbage can i
got to tell you that's the only thing
i'm concerned about and we have law
enforcement watching every one of them
but they have they have and you have to
watch them too
15 days from now we're going to win the
state of arizona and we're going to win
four more years way
everybody needs to get out and vote
return your absentee ballot today or
vote early in person as soon as you can
when is that starting the early when
does that start now
now get out now right
i like that better oh
you know you always get this but yeah
and your state is doing great you have a
great governor as you know
and your state is doing great with a
pandemic
pandemic they're getting tired of the
pandemic aren't they
getting tired of the people you turn on
cnn that's all they cover
covet covert pandemic cove at cove cove
you know why they're trying to talk
everybody out of voting people aren't
buying at cnn you dumb bastards they're
not
that's all they talk about
i watch this guy's got lousy ratings
fredo you know fredo
got horrible ratings he's talking about
the pandemic that's all they talk about
you know i don't know he said he had it
i'm i'm not sure he had it he went to
the basement
it's the only time his ratings were up
people want to see what was going to
happen
he'll probably get it again even though
in theory you're not supposed to be able
to
well i had it and they say you're not
going to catch it again and that's okay
with me
that's okay with me oh were they happy
when they heard i had it right did you
see it
they were trying well we hope he gets
better
you know we hope he gets better and then
i came out and i did a rally and i said
this guy hasn't changed
actually i say i'm not saying i don't
know if this is a compliment
they said he looks better now than
before he had it what's that all about
what's that who knows if you have it you
have it you get better but we have great
therapeutics
we had i took something uh regeneron
which we're making available to
everybody free
but to me it was a cure it wasn't a pen
it
really it wasn't a therapeutic to me it
was a cure i took it
i didn't feel so great i will tell you
that i don't like to admit that but for
a long time
and i didn't feel too great and when
you're president you have a lot of
doctors checking you out
right i told the story last night we
went by the way these rallies
they're unbelievable and i like this
better remember
we're outside they all want us to be
outside you know
they're they're all wanting us to be
outside and
these are outdoor rallies and we can
hold more people that we can in the
arenas
these are the biggest rallies these are
the biggest rallies
ever had in history by a political
candidate
they won't say that
no it's great that's good but i took it
and it was incredible
incredible and i was out i took it i
felt like superman the next morning i
woke up
let me add him with your vote we will
continue to cut your taxes and
regulations
to maintain your energy independence
strengthen our military
support our great police protect our
second amendment which is under siege
defend our borders arrest violent
criminals and confirm
more judges to uphold the rule of law
we have a record number of judges you
see that
a record number of federal judges so we
have a great one right now hopefully
gets approved next week
amy under my leadership prosperity will
search
patriotism will soar optimism will boom
the pandemic will soon end it's rounding
the corner they hate it when i say it
you know they always like to say about
europe and this and that really oh
really how they doing
how they doing i'll tell you what and
we're working with them
we're sending them ventilators we're
sending them everything but we're
rounding the turn we're going to have
the
vaccine but with or without it it's
happening soon by the way
it would even happen sooner if we didn't
have these characters on the other side
the democrats that are running all these
failed cities the democrats are running
your failed cities you know that right
and states but if they weren't talking
because they don't want it to be
you know they they don't want it to be
successful i really mean it
but ultimately it's going to all come
together because
it was coming together and then we got
hit by the china plague we were going to
all be
well unified people were calling me that
you would have never expected
it was coming together because of
success and then we got hit by the
plague
we closed up which we did a great thing
we saved 2 million lives or more
2 million lives we did a great job we
never got credit for
we helped all of the states and the
governors some did a good job some did a
horrible job i'll tell you who they are
one day do i have the all-time great
book
i have the real book right
but like a lot of these other people i
don't like writing books while i'm
running
i don't like writing books while we're
in office because
you don't do that normal life will
rapidly return that's what we want
normal go take us back seven
and next year will be the greatest
economic year in the history of our
country that's what's going to happen
and we're going to cut your taxes this
guy's going to raise your taxes by four
times think of it
and now he's saying well maybe i won't
take away the tax cuts because he said
we're going to earn the trump tax cuts
they said well
it's going to ultimately be eight
thousand dollars of family
he said well maybe we won't end up that
doesn't sound so good
he has look he's gonzo folks he's gone
he has no idea and the people that are
running that party are radical
far left maniacs and you can't let this
this is the most
important election in the history of our
country
this is election that's a choice between
a trump recovery
at the highest end or abiding depression
you're going to have
with what he's going to do with
regulations what he's going to do with
taxes every company that came in from
europe from asia
every company is going to leave as soon
as the i'll tell you what
even the thought of it as an example
foxconn
foxconn in wisconsin incredible company
it makes a lot
of the apple equipment stuff right the
phones the iphones the ipads
incredible company they don't like the
democrat governor they don't want to
spend the money they want to come in and
spend a lot of money
they don't like the possibility that a
sleepy joke could get in they don't want
to invest billions of dollars in having
those policies so they pull back if
trump
gets in they will spend billions and
billions and billions not your state
but wisconsin probably your state too
billions of dollars
but we speak to them they're unhappy
when they see this democrat
kind of leadership or even the chance
that it is so where do you see what
foxconn does in wisconsin okay different
place
but what do you see if we win they will
make an investment the likes of which
our country has rarely seen before
but this is all a choice between getting
a safe vaccine
or really a lockdown you know biden
wants to lock it down he wants to listen
to
dr fauci who wants to listen to dr
fountz
and don't forget dr fauci what he said
is no no don't close it to china i said
i'm sorry doctor you're a wonderful man
and
he is a nice man you're a wonderful man
i'm closing it
i saved thousands of lives he admitted
that two months later
two months later and dr fauci said don't
put on masks don't
you see the thing and now he says put on
masks and they say you know he's a
wonderful guy and he is a wonderful guy
i like him he just happens to have a
very bad arm
he has a bad arm but he's a good guy
he's a good guy a lot of our people
don't like him i like him you have to
understand him he's a promoter
and it's a choice between the american
dream or a totally
socialist nightmare that's what you'll
have you'll be a socialist country and i
said
our country will never be a socialist
country we're not going
joe biden has made a corrupt bargain by
the way he's made many corrupt bargains
if you've been ready
you know he's all shut down again can
you believe it he's going
live you know lid means lid means a
politician goes into
i guess a garbage can or something with
the lid they put the lid on it right i
guess i don't know maybe it's something
else that
sounds no there's an expression that
kept saying sir uh
the vice president our vice president
pence is working his ass off i'll tell
you he's
he's all over the place he's great did
he do a good job against kamala
if that were a fight they would have
stopped it now pence is great
but uh they put the lid on it every day
you wake up
where's biden today sir uh he's lit it
out
he's lit it out what does that mean that
means he's going to stay in the basement
all day
but i think today he's staying in the
basement to talk to his lawyers they
caught him called
they taught him
i'll tell you something i mean this so
he is lucky
that we have in our country and they
don't appreciate
a wonderful human being and the most
fair
attorney general of the united states
because i know people
that would have had him locked up five
weeks ago
bill barr is a very nice man
and a very fair man and they have no
idea because somebody else would have
taken that thing
and all the crap and corruption he's
been a corrupt politician for a long
time this guy
and in many ways it doesn't make some of
us happy
but in many ways bill barr is a
wonderful human being and a very fair
person
and he's not a person that wants to hurt
people just remember that
i say it and i say it once just remember
it
because i get angry too but just
remember
he's a very fair man and in many ways
and especially in that position
there's something very nice about it
okay so what can i say
joe biden has made a corrupt bargain in
exchange for his party's nomination
he has handed control of his whole group
over to the socialists the communist the
marxist and the left-wing
extremists you know that you see them
marching up the streets in these
democrat-run cities
you don't see them in the republican-run
cities they're in charge and they are
calling the shots
if elected biden will delay the
therapies look i mean even the vaccines
they're trying to say oh it's no good if
trump has it
it's being done by johnson and johnson
fisa
that i don't even know who these people
are right if it comes out with trump
how bad is that they are willing to
demean a vaccine
for political purposes i saw it this
morning if it's
no no i saw it this morning where
a governor who's done a truly poor
thousands tens of thousands of people
have died in the state andrew cuomo
he's done a terrible job eleven thousand
people died in a nursing home he could
have put him in the convention center
that i built
he we opened up 2800 beds we moved the
big hospital ship
it was empty he could have put him there
he put him back in
infected people back in with our elderly
population
knowing that our elderly population is
susceptible andrew cuomo he killed
thousands and thousands of people
probably listened to his brother fredo
you know fredo
rado now it's a shame and you know
it's just a shame but i saw him he was
knocking the faction
if the vaccine comes out during the
trump administration
we're not going to use it it's nothing
to do with me it's johnson and johnson
it's fiza
it's modern these are the greatest
companies in the world has nothing to do
with me
we need a vaccine and when it's ready it
should come out already
it could in my opinion except for
politics they just don't want it to come
out before the election
but you know what i'm the one that did
it this thing wouldn't be here for two
years and they're ready to come
but it's a shame it's a shame
when you try and demean something so
important for politics it's a shame but
they'd like to postpone the vaccine
prolong the pandemic close your schools
shut down your country we're not doing
it by the way you have
you have a great governor the way he did
it
you have a great fellow he's here
someplace we're gonna introduce where
the hell is it
where's that though i don't get up yet
i'll let you
you'll have yours don't get too much
sunburn
the governor didn't tell me it's going
to be this hot out here
does anybody have a little sunblock i'd
love to use it right now
i'm always preaching to my kids sunblock
sunblock and here i am like an idiot but
that's a
he'll massively raise your taxes bite
and he's going to raise your taxes
first time i've ever heard of a
politician he wants
he's running on raising taxes that's how
crazy the world has become
all my life i see politicians they want
to cut your taxes we're going to cut
your taxes
the other guy says we're going to cut it
more well this is an easy one for me
then
because we're cutting we gave you the
greatest biggest tax cut
in history and he's going to give you
the biggest tax cut in reverse because
what he's doing he's going to end ours
but he's going to give you
the biggest tax increase in the history
of our country
now now think of it think of it who the
hell can win with that platform
and if you listen to these this election
is tied
with three points up in your state but i
don't know i think how can you be three
points up when we have crowds like this
and nobody shows up
three points three points
now so he wants so we're cutting your
taxes he's
increasing your taxes just those two
things
isn't that sort of the end of the
election now we can make the case
you know something's good it will
destroy your
401ks it will destroy the stock market
which is ready to reach
new historic can you imagine rounding
the turn on the pandemic
and we have the highest stock market
we've ever had think of this
and some of our numbers are higher than
they were
housing and different things some of our
numbers are higher than they were
even before the pandemic i mean it's
pretty amazing
you know why because we built such a
strong foundation
if we didn't have that strong foundation
this would be a disaster
he wants to bury you in regulations
outsource your jobs
dismantle your police departments
dissolve our borders he doesn't want
borders
the wall by the way is almost finished
and you have the strongest southern
border you've ever had
he wants to confiscate your guns get rid
of your second amendment
he wants to ban american energy no
fracking
how about that for a year and a half he
says no fracking then he goes
to pennsylvania we have a million jobs
the state is dependent on it and all of
a sudden he says oh
well i guess we can fight and the press
doesn't call him because
they are more corrupt than biden himself
they want to wipe out your private
health care plans a lot of people have
180 million
people have private health care and they
love it
they're so happy and it's all going to
disappear
you will be able to go to your local
hospital ward
and stand in line for six weeks when you
have a cold or when you have something
worse
this is what's going to happen he wants
to terminate your religious liberty
destroy the suburbs they're not
destroyed
we ended the regulation i ended it you
know that
women of the suburbs please raise your
hands
okay look at it look at that crowd
so women of the suburbs look here's the
story women of the sub
the fake news has been saying the women
of the
they said this last time too women don't
like trump and then they saw
then they saw 52 voted for trump right
i said why don't they like me they don't
like me they couldn't give and then
after we won they said
women came out for trump what happened
women i like women
i like women so anyway
no but listen here's the story they said
suburban women i used to call them
suburban housewives i got killed all the
time i said uh
i better go politically correct and i'll
bet there's not
is there one woman here that minds being
called if you're married at least
a suburban housewife
the only one that she wants to because
he said
no the only one that minded those
characters a lot of people up there
the press right that's the only one the
rest of them though but
you know what in keeping with in keeping
with our modern era and
being politically correct so the women
of the suburbs
so you have a regulation now that's a
disaster
it allows low-income housing to be built
right next to your american dream
what ultimately it means is crime will
come pouring and you know what these
antifa people
and the radical left and it is the
radical left
it is the radical left the radical left
the next place they want to hit at the
suburbs they say it all over
right and what i did with the regulation
my people came and he's great ben carson
dr
ben carson he's great
but ben came to me so we can i say i
want to get rid of that regulation
it's a horrible regulation getting worse
all the time
and i've watched it for years you've all
watched it right where they destroyed
these
incredible communities and ben said well
we can really
bring it down and make it much more
palatable i said no ben you know what
that's going to be more controversial
terminated he said yes sir he terminated
we terminated
it you have no more regulation now if
sleepy crazy crooked joe gets in
i don't know he shouldn't be allowed to
run frank
if that were me if that were me they
wouldn't allow me to run
if that were me can you imagine if don
jr
had the problems of where's hunter right
don jr oh my poor boy boy what that
boy's been through
what that guy's been through i don't
know ivanka's different she sort of
floats through life
she's pretty amazing i tell you she's
pretty amazing
and eric eric has been great but what
they went after my kids
and i restrict them from doing things i
mean can you imagine the money my kids
could be
dad let's build a hotel in saudi arabia
i restricted him and said he can't do
anything
let's go build a couple of hotels in uh
in uh
name any place in the world we'll have
them right and you know all the money
that biden's raising he did 350 million
i would be doug the greatest [ __ ] i'd
make doug look like a bad fundraiser
i would be the greatest fundraiser in
history
all i have to do is call up the head of
every wall street firm head of every
major company head of every major energy
company
do me a favor send me 10 million for my
campaign yes sir
they say the only thing is why didn't
you ask for more sir
said i would i would be i would take in
more money but you know what
i don't want to do that because if i do
that i'm totally compromised
because when they call me you know
you're a loyal person and what happens
is hey you know you'll do things that
are a lot more money so when the press
says and we're raising a lot of money
we're raising a lot of small money a lot
of 61
62 you know no republicans ever done
that but when i started calling i would
be
i would be the greatest fundraiser in
history don't forget i'm not bad at that
stuff anyway
and i'm president so i called some guy
the head of
exxon i called the head of exxon i don't
know but
you know i'll use a cup hi how you doing
how's energy coming when are you doing
the exploration oh you need a couple of
permits huh
okay but i call the head of exxon i say
you know i'd love to send me 25 million
dollars for the campaign
absolutely sir why didn't you would you
like some more
and if i make the call now people make
the call it's different you know but if
i made the call
i will hit a home run every single call
i would raise a billion dollars in one
day if i wanted to
i don't want to do that i don't want to
do it
i put in a lot of money when i ran
originally i put in a lot of money into
this campaign you know my
primary campaign and i never thought it
was appreciated they don't even they'd
never give me credit for it
but i gave up my salary you know i gave
up
so the has paid no but nobody ever talks
about it
you know every month there's sleaze
because there's leaves most of them not
all that guy's a good guy
but that he really you do have a couple
of good guys but not many
but every month they call and has the
president giving up his check
i don't have to you know i'm the only
president they say maybe i'm wrong
they'll say
you know 100 years ago somebody else did
i'm the only president
that did not accept the salary
which surprised me you know
it's 450 000 the only reason i mentioned
it is they never talk about it they
never talk about
but what they do do is they call up
every month
did he give up his check and kaylee
where's kaylee is she here
where's candy i'm grateful where's
kaylee kaylee
come here kelly
wait so she just recovered
from covid
can you believe it stay away from me
kaylee
no kaylee is it true they call
all the time did he give up his check
his salary check
and she's always okay they never write
about that
if i ever didn't give it up it would be
headlines trump refused
these people are the worst but is that
true kaylee say a couple of words
that is absolutely true mr president and
let me tell you this guys
with your help we can beat social media
we can beat the media
because we have the greatest fighter in
the history of this country
and president donald j trump
thank you she's so great
she is so great
i didn't know she would be that good
that was good sometimes they get people
up and they bomb
you know they bomb you know she's
married to a professional major league
baseball player he got lucky
he got lucky thanks kaley but it's true
it's true but i'd be the greatest
fundraiser of all time
for the last 47 years sleepy joe biden
shipped away your jobs
shut down your factories threw open your
borders
and ravaged our cities while sacrificing
american blood
and treasure in these ridiculous endless
foreign wars of countries that you've
never even heard about right you never
even heard their name
so sad they're all coming back you know
that joe biden
is a servant of the globalists and the
lobbyists and the wealthy donors the
people that i could be calling oh would
i have fun
i would have fun i'd like to come maybe
i should call and put the money in
escrow and just give it back to him
and the washington vultures who got rich
bleeding america dry
that's what happened including big
pharma in 2016
you voted to fire this corrupt and
decrepit political establishment that
you elected an
outsider as president who is finally
putting
america first it's about time
56 did you see this fifth
we're in a pandemic okay
because of china we're in a pandemic a
poll just came out gallop
56 of the american people in this brand
new poll just came out
gallup poll say they are better off
today than they were
four years ago under obama by the
administration
and it's a record number
will you do me a favor one just one
favorite today
will you please go out and elect martha
stand up
great great pilot
when we came in low with the helicopter
she sit away she could have been 200
feet lower
i said that we would only had ten feet
clearance she said not
okay she was a great pilot the warthog
she flew the warthogs are
an incredible planet
get her elected will you please i don't
want to waste we don't want to waste a
lot of time arthur get her elected okay
that other guy he's bad news i mean he's
good if you
don't like does anybody not like your
second amendment here
because he will vote to get rid of your
second amendment you know that you know
i mean i know the whole thing in the
history and it's a sad deal and all of
that stuff
but he's a radical leftist that he's
going to vote to take away your guns
somehow somehow arizona and no guns
don't seem to match up very well
he's going to take away and i'm i'm much
more blunt i think than
martha she's a nicer person than i am i
say it very directly
he's going to vote to take away your
guns now i don't know that he'll be
successful because hopefully he's going
to have to go through me but what the
hell do we need that there for
she will be a great senator and she has
been
a great senator and you know she was
appointed by
doug and doug is one of the best
governors in the country
and he didn't close you down and you
couldn't breathe like in michigan
you know the court the supreme court
overruled her in michigan
and you know part of the problem she had
the only one that had his freedom was
her husband he was allowed to go
swimming fishing boating everybody else
is on shore they see this guy boating
and who was it it was the husband of the
governor of michigan
that didn't help their case by the way
but
but no i mean the people in michigan i
love them we're leading in the polls in
michigan
but think of it you know why because we
have many car plants they didn't have a
car plant opening in 42 years
and then i came along now they got so
many of them they don't know what the
hell to do we'll send some to arizona
okay
and you already have them opening up in
arizona no
but you know they gotta open up the
states they got to let the kids go back
to school baron
barron trump barron trump had it all
these young guys
baron trump had it he's very you know
he's 14
and he's very tall he is very tall
but baron had it and the doctor said
our first lady had and i had baron at it
sir
baron tested positive i said oh wow
how's he going to do very good sir no
problem i said good like
14 minutes later how's barrett do how's
he doing doc how's my boy doing
uh sir he's cured that happened
you know it took about 12 seconds
how's baron doing doc i want to be i
want to make sure my baron's okay
sir he's fine what do you mean he's fine
no he's all 100
can you believe it because i hate to
admit it all of us people that are
slightly older
their immune system is uh strong very
strong
so baron had it it came it went he's
immune
you know that's the way it is oh those
kids those
kids i looked at baron like he was
superman i said baron you're my man
i said how you feeling he didn't even
know what he was talking about actually
joe biden as always and has been a
corrupt politician
and as far as i'm concerned the biden
family is a criminal enterprise if you
read
if you read if you read this uh
laptop i tell you what this is called
the laptop from hell the only laptop
that was almost as good maybe worse
was the laptop of anthony weiner
do you remember that ding ding ding ding
he got hacked too just like scully got
hacked remember he said he got hacked
he was sending messages to very very
young
women girls girls excuse me girls
he was sending messages a lot of them
and
uh he got hacked they always say they
got hacked scully got hacked right
scully
he was a never trumper he got hacked you
know
i've never known a person that said he
got hacked they got hacked
nobody gets hacked to get hacked you
need somebody with a 197 iq
and he needs about 15 of your password
right
it doesn't happen so scully got hacked
and now on thursday
i go up another another real great one
another great one kristen welker
she's a radical democrat look at them
they're getting angry she's a radical
democrat
she deleted her entire account
everything is deleted
but i've known her she's been screaming
questions at me for
a long time and uh she's no good
but i figured what the hell she asked
your question how did i do the other
night against one that was worse
she was worse savannah
so i had savannah guthrie the other
night she was
she was like a crazed lunatic
she was literally rising out of her
chair or she's screaming questions
and how about that great woman behind me
she kept going
i love her i don't know too much i met
her right after she's great but i tell
you
she was definitely a trump person they
made a big mistake you know the mistake
they made was
they forgot to check the audience the
audience was great
and how about the woman that came up and
said i love your
you're smile handsome you're so handsome
you're so handsome when you smile
i love your smile sir could i ask and
she was so nice
and then what happened is nbc which is
the worst that's comcast i call it khan
c-o-n because they can't
you know they spend a fortune in public
relations and i talk about them
wipes out their whole year of public
relations con they're comcast
they're dishonest people okay totally
dishonest so she said
really i mean look this woman likes me i
know when somebody likes me i know when
they don't like me
it's very quick it takes me like a
fraction of a second
i love your smile sir you're so handsome
when you smile you're so
could i ask you okay okay
ready now they grab it they said this is
not working out well
so they grab her and i did you know i
was longer
and they interview her after i do not
like him
i do not they told her you can't do that
you got to say bad things i have no
doubt because i watched her interviewed
afterwards
she hated my dad she was going like i
don't like her
i'm going to vote for biden why because
he's a genius no
why are you voting for him i have no
idea so that's what happens
we're dealing with a corrupt crooked
media just remember that
and i'm glad i came along because
there's no other human being on earth
other than maybe doug ducey
that could have handled the crap that
i've had to handle i'll tell you what
every other person even a tough person
would have been in a corner long ago
with his thumb in his mouth saying mommy
mommy take me home right
they would have said mommy please i
can't take it
but me i viewed it as a challenge and
what what it really is is
we're exposing some real garbage
and you know these tech companies are
very dangerous because they refuse to
allow
even the new york post which deserves
tremendous credit
they caught biden in a scandal the likes
of which we haven't seen i say the
second worst
in the history of our country the first
worst was when they spied
on the president of the united states
and tried to take him down
and they spied and they got caught let's
see what happens
let's see what happens that's to be the
worst this could
this is the second but this could be
leading into the first i mean you know
this is
this is this is a grave grave problem
but you're lucky i'm your president
you're so lucky here so long
i always tell our great first lady
darling you're so lucky i took you on
this wonderful journey as we get
hammered by these fake people we get
hammered every day and i say darling
you're so lucky i took you on this chair
uh but they do love michelle obama
they love michelle you know did you hear
the new one
they came up to me sir i have bad news
what president obama is going to start
campaigning for sleepy joe i said
is that good or bad news because don't
forget he campaigned for hillary harder
than hillary did
right he said he will not get the
nomination i got the nomination
he actually said he will not run iran he
will not get the nomination
he will not be your president and became
the president
ducey thought i was gonna win anyway no
he's gonna you know the funny thing
about obama
look they work together for a long time
like i work with mike pence they work
together for a long time
and he tried to talk him out of it
because he knows he's not mentally fit
to be president
we can't play games you know we can be
nice and say oh he's wonderful he's not
wonderful
you know two days ago he said uh it is
very
my much uh really great honor to be uh
running as a democrat for the united
states senate and he meant it
with me i'd be joking maybe and they say
oh the guy meant it
that's about the third time he said that
too that's a little bit scary see that's
not like
something that you know you pronounce a
word wrong or something
that's serious problems and when he says
that like
it's great to be with you people today
in the great state of ohio
and they say you're in arizona oh i
meant arizona i love the people
you know i always say he's done that
eight times now where he's i've never
done it
i've never done it when i do perhaps
it's time to retire
you know if you do that it's
disqualifying because
it's so bad like you could be you know
winston churchill was a great great
speaker
you could do that so we're in arizona
and if i said
i love the people of ohio and it's great
to be with you today right
the worst was when i think he said he
was in palm beach
and your palm trees and he said it's
great to be with the people of iowa
right
right you know there's something wrong
here
something going on right but he said
just three times
recently but the last two days ago that
he's running for the
u.s senate and uh i'm actually happy
he's running for this because i mean
hey look he's the worst
presidential pick in the history of
presidential politics i think
and i i say this and you know they
always take that one little say have you
seen how dishonest they are
they'll take that one little section i
say if i lose to him it'll be a disgrace
so they don't put the first part in they
don't put the end in
they just president trump thinks he's
going to lose
because they take that one little
section so i have to be very very
careful the way
because they're so corrupt and so
dishonest but it is true he's probably
the worst in the history of presidential
politics
win lose or draw whittle is a draw this
man should not be your president
number one he's corrupt number two he's
not a smart man never was
number three he's seen better days so
are you ready to let's get isn't this
better than reading the stupid
teleprompter
so if i don't sound like a typical
washington politician
it's because i'm not a politician
if i don't always play by the rules of
the washington establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you
harder than any president has ever
fought before
we're not going to lose our nation to
socialist
we're not going to be losing our nation
to kamala who's further left than bernie
i'd rather have bernie than kamala
and you'll have a woman president
someday but it's not going to be kamala
you don't want that as your first woman
you don't want kamala furthest left
and she treated biden so badly there was
nobody that you
and her pulled them but she was tagged
she left
i don't know that's the kind of thinking
you've got that's the kind of thinking
you're
you're supposed to be voting for i guess
i'm fighting so hard because i love my
country so much
and because i'm determined to ensure
that the forgotten men and women of this
country are never
forgotten again that happened
so we're joined by a great group of
warriors and i
i really would love just to come up for
a second you do have a great
governor and a great friend of mine doug
ducey come on up doug and senator
martha mcsally come on
donald trump will win the state of
arizona
donald trump will be returned to the
white house
and on november 3rd martha mcsally will
join him in the united states senate and
they will give us conservative
judges on the supreme court
they will support the cause of life
and they will confirm amy coney barrett
joe biden is wrong for america
joe biden would pack the supreme court
joe biden would make washington
d.c a state
joe biden's got to be sent back to the
basement
on november 3rd
and on november 3rd we will return
donald j trump and mike pence as
president and vice president of the
united states back to the white house
thank you so much welcome back to
arizona president trump let's give it up
for the president
arizona you know we have a choice people
are voting right now
we have a choice we are on the verge of
a great american comeback and it's going
to be greater because we're bringing
jobs home from china
with president trump
we're going gonna make sure we support
our men and women in blue and our border
patrol
we keep america strong and safe
and you know that other choice is a joe
biden
and my opponent mark kelly who would be
who would be chuck schumer's 51st vote
to ram through their radical agenda to
pack the courts
to open our borders to pass the green
bad deal
tax increases taking away our second
amendment you know that
arizona's not gonna let that happen
and you know in my race it's not just
whether you like
a fighter pilot or an astronaut and i
know you guys like a fighter pilot
mark kelly brought a communist china
communist banner to space with him
and flew the amer the communist of the
chinese flag on his motorcycle
i fly the american flag mark
mark kelly's spokesman called police
officers worthless effing pigs
and he still works for him i backed the
blue i got the blue with president trump
mark kelly's organization you know the
radical
gun grabbing organization they gave
california an
a grade for their gun control policies
and they gave and they gave arizona and
f
i got an idea why don't we give mark
kelly an f and tell him to go run in
california if he likes him so much
and mark kelly said that he would not
vote for amy coney barrett i'm flying on
air force one tonight
with president trump back to d.c and
we're not leaving until we put judge
barrett on the bench
arizonans we're ground zero
the country is relying on us this state
will decide to send president trump back
for four more years
this state will decide the senate
majority in stopping the radical left in
my race
this state will save the supreme court
and save the country
president trump in the country is
relying on us let's win in november god
bless you let's bring it back home
thank you look at that crowd i wish
these people would
hey can you put the cameras back there
please will you turn one of your cameras
back
as far as the eye can see its people
unbelievable
unbelievable
they never do it you know they never
turn the camera i used to think they
couldn't you know physically it was like
stuck
they couldn't do it but they can't
because whenever there's a little
problem that thing goes like a pretzel
it's unbelievable
but they never want to show these crowds
they never want to do it because they're
fake
listen we have a congressman who's a
friend of mine who's a warrior paul
gosar where's paul
where's paul thank you paul a warrior
a warrior and a friend of ours who's
incredible she's
leading from what i'm hearing tiffany i
hear she's leading
congressional candidate tiffany shed
tiffany you're leading in the poll
wow that's a long way she's incredible
what a great career and that you're
doing this is so great
thank you tiffany tiffany shed get out
and vote for
and a friend of mine somebody that was
great she would have been
uh if she didn't have three four people
running at the same time
she would have been your senator hate to
say it you would have been your senator
a friend that's uh so loyal and
strong but and a good person arizona gop
chair kelly ward she's worked so hard
she is some warrior and fighter and just
they don't even understand it okay i
don't even understand you sometimes
kelly you don't
she doesn't give up how are we doing
kelly
we're winning we're winning yeah good
get out there
15 days kelly everybody don't sleep
don't go to bed don't sleep
right and sergeant jimmy
chavez of the national troopers
coalition jimmy where's jimmy
jimmy thank you for everything jimmy
thank you for everything and i was
recently honored
to receive the coalition's endorsement
and i want to thank
you you're really amazing thank you jeff
and a tough guy and a good guy in
addition i was just named i have to say
this
man of the year by law enforcement's big
magazine it's called blue magazine
man of the year i love law enforcement
so we're delighted to be joined by a
legendary quarterback i used to watch
this guy you know he'd win with the
brain
as well as the body jim mcmahon two-time
all-american at brigham young
and later a two-time super bowl champion
where's jim where is he i love that guy
look at him
look at that guy look at that guy
i'll tell you and i love your coach too
i love mike
and i love single terry you know single
terry likes trump you know that right
you think singletary's tough enough how
was he tough enough
look at him he just he's all business
he's taking those pictures
that's him jim you were a winner man and
you are a winner i mean it too
and say hello to ditka and say hello to
singletary and all those guys what a
great team
right that was a team of champions you
know you win with a muscle but you got
to win with this too
you got to win with this too we just uh
we just gave out a presidential medal to
a great fighter dan does everybody know
our dan
right out of iowa huh and how about jim
jordan is he a great one jim jordan
right he was a great wrestler
we had so many uh we have so many people
that are behind us
anyway great to be with you jim thank
you very much for coming we appreciate
it
dan gable everybody you know dan gable
did you ever have dan gable
hey jim he was 182 wins
and one loss he won everything
and he was an unbelievable coach at iowa
dan gable
and then think of it a career
182 in one in fact i asked who was the
one
i guess he was pretty good but he ended
up beating him
in the olympics and then he went to the
olympics and he won the olympic gold
medal dan gable any wrestling person
would know
and in iowa dan gable is like a legend
and he is all over the country and
in the wrestling world the greatest ever
and
he goes to the olympics and he never
lost a point
and in the final he had to wrestle the
russian who was supposed to be
unbeatable but he was supposed to be
unbeatable too
and he beat the russian and never
allowed a point he went through the
entire schedule
and never allowed one point think about
that and he won the olympic gold medal
and dan gable is now getting the
presidential
medal of freedom he's coming to the
white house so that's pretty cool
thank you joe under my administration we
built the greatest economy in the
history of the world
and now we're doing it again you know
it's make america great again right
so now i go make america great again
again
make it great again again and that's
what we're doing we're way ahead of
schedule in my first three years we
increased family income
by over six thousand dollars more than
five
times the game think of this five times
the gain
we were actually more than that more
than five times a game
in all eight years under the last
administration
five times a game in a much shorter
period of time african-american
unemployment and hispanic american
unemployment and asian-american
on american employment think of that we
all reached
the lowest levels in the history of our
country
african-american asian-american
hispanic-american we lifted 6.6 million
americans out of poverty
including more than 1.5 million hispanic
americans who
are liking trump a lot i like you too
i don't know if you see what's happening
with hispanic americans we
are leading them in the polls where it's
never happened before
i've always liked hispanics and they
liked me
this was not in their this was not
supposed to be happening but i love the
hispanic americans and they're doing
great
and by the way they're great business
people our policies are lifting up all
americans of every income
since the china virus we've created a
record 11.4 million american jobs think
of that
you know we they just announced think of
this it sounds terrible in one way
but you were hearing numbers like 42
percent unemployment you know
it's not everybody's fault except china
it came in
and you're hearing it could be 42 38
whatever
so they just announced it 7.8
unemployment
we're going to be back to where we were
very soon
unless you put a fool into office who's
going to raise your taxes and
put back all the regulations where every
company's going to leave
now think of it doesn't 7.8 you know one
way i don't like to say it
because we're down to 3.4 3.5
but 7.8 if you would have heard that
three four five months ago you would
have said impossible and we'll be back
to the same number and next year will be
stronger than ever before you watch
after the virus left china we experience
the smallest contraction of any major
western country
and the fastest recovery by far of any
country think of that
as president i've been delivering for
the incredible hispanic american
community like
never before i'm fighting for school
choice
for safe neighborhoods for
hispanic-owned small businesses
i have a couple of them some of where my
friends with the restaurant oh they're
doing so well
they made a lot of money my restaurant
a couple of people didn't like that
restaurant i liked it and now they have
lines around the block joe biden would
obliterate everything hispanic americans
have worked for wiping out your
small businesses with lockdowns and
regulations
and devastating your families with
massive tax
he wants to give you the big big fat tax
hikes
he will wage war on catholic
organizations
ban charter schools bankrupt catholic
schools we've already taken care of the
funding for catholic schools
fund extremely term abortion and let
socialists run wild in our country
and that's why we're going to win a
record share of the hispanic vote
there will never be a share of the
hispanic vote like this unless we decide
to run again in four years and then
another run
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military
we have the best equipment of any
country in the world
we've upgraded our nuclear to a level
that it's never even been close to
we have new rockets and missiles and
ships and tanks
what we have is incredible the f-35
fighter jet the best in the world
stealth
tankers new tankers new freighters we
have everything
2.5 trillion dollars all made in the usa
we are the envy of russia
we are the envy of china nobody has the
equipment
even the hydrosonic missiles that obama
messed up on
we have hydrosonic missiles they go
seven times faster
than a normal missile we have the best
hydrosonic in the world you know
they stole our plans during the obama
administration another thing that
happened
these are little things that happen that
we don't that i won't tell anybody okay
we also pass for our veterans va choice
and va accountability everyone
said that would have been impossible
and last year american warriors killed
the founder and leader of isis
al-baghdadi
we killed al-baghdadi baghdadi we have a
very special person with us today
just days ago my administration brought
two depraved isis terrorists known as
the beatles
from the united kingdom these were two
bad ones
these are people i would have liked to
give to jim and his team to work over
jim would have liked that i think it
would have been very happy
to stand trial for killing of four
american hostages
peter kasich stephen sotloff
james foley and kayla mueller
as many of you know kayla came from
right here in
prescott arizona beautiful beautiful
girl
and we're deeply moved and she's been
uh thought of all the time her family as
you know her mother and father came and
they spoke beautifully at the republican
national convention but we're deeply
moved to be joined by her
incredible and loving family her dad
carl
her mom marsha and the entire family
we will hold kayla's precious memory in
our hearts forever
just special please stand please
please
please
please
you look younger since i last saw you
you know i'm looking
you look very good i want to thank you
very much what an incredible
story and you said if we were here if we
were here earlier instead of obama she
would have been
with us today she would have been with
us today and that's true
that's true they couldn't they could
have done that they didn't do it
they just talk they talk all the time
they don't do it i want to thank you
very much
incredible her memory will never ever be
forgotten right
and what a story it is what a vicious
story what a horrible story but he's
dead
we also took out
they've been looking for him for many
years he was the founder of isis and he
was rebuilding it because we obliterated
the isis
100 of the isis caliphate and he was
looking to build it again and we got him
and you know the guys that got him i'm a
story that not a lot of people know
i think it was uh kayla's birth date
right they used the birthdate
as the number and they talked that
number that specific number
that was their code name for taking out
this horrible al-baghdadi right
great honor they don't do that often
they don't do that often but they use
her
her birthday and then they took him out
they didn't play games and
a dog on that one became more famous
than i did and that's good
that dog was a hell of a dog and still
is we also took out the mass murder of
american troops and a lot of other
people and a lot of other troops
solimani is dead solomani another one
and i withdrew from the last
administration's disastrous iran nuclear
deal
i recognized the true capital of israel
and opened the
american embassy in jerusalem
every president talked about that for
decades and decades and then they got to
be president and they never did a damn
thing about it i did it i got it done i
even got it built
for a tiny fraction of the cost you know
that store i also recognize israeli
sovereignty over the golan heights for
52 years they were talking
i got it done in about two hours and
instead of endless war in the middle
east we're forging peace in the middle
east
nations are joining one after another
the fact is i did more in 47 months
than sleepy joe biden did in 47 years
except what he did for himself
a vote for republican is a vote for safe
communities great jobs
and a limitless future for all americans
and this is such an important state if
we win this state we win it all this is
such an important story
and i happen to love this state so in
conclusion
over the next four years we will make
america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all it's already started
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults and law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
second amendment
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens
and we will keep america out of endless
foreign wars
they're coming home they're all coming
home
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will ensure peace through
strength and that's what we have
we will end surprise medical billing
require
price transparency which is even more
important you will find than health care
and it's already signed i did it
goes into effect on january 1st i said
couldn't you have made it like a little
back further they said statutorily sir
but it's already signed and done nobody
can believe it
further reduce the cost of prescription
drugs favored nations and drug companies
don't like me too much
and we will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon
and the united states will be the first
nation to land
an astronaut on mars and it's happening
quickly
and we now again with nasa have by far
the preeminent
space center anywhere in the world not
even close and it was closed it was dead
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
school
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great
american flag
we will live by the timeless words of
our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america
and standing up for the great people of
arizona
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors get your co-workers get
your boss
get out and vote get out there right
away right away right
right now from phoenix
to flagstaff from tombstone to prescott
from mesa to yuma to red rock
sedona and all over the place this is so
beautiful
how good is this place huh you got the
most beautiful
sedona we stand on the shoulders of
red-blooded american patriots
who poured out their heart sweat and
soul
for our liberty and our freedom this
great state was settled by some of the
toughest men
and strongest women ever to walk on the
earth jim are you from here originally
because you're tough
you're so tough you're close enough
he's close today's so tough arizona's
where wired earp
and dark holiday became american legends
wyatt earp right
that's a good one that's a good one to
have
it's where the great american west
became
the american dream and arizona is the
state where generations of pioneers and
prospectors and minors and ranchers
cowboys and cattle hands marshals and
lawmen
tame the frontier braved the blazing sun
like i'm doing right now i'm gonna pay
for this
i'm gonna pay for this see i'm giving
you the full show i could have left here
a half an hour ago i'm giving you i said
to hell with it
when you see me tomorrow and i look like
a lobster remember you did it
and showed the entire world how the west
was won
they helped make america into the
greatest nation in the history of the
world
and the best is yet to come it's coming
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning power
to you the american people with your
help
your devotion and your drive we are
going to keep on working
we are going to keep on fighting and we
are going to keep on
winning winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of arizona
we have made america powerful again
we have made america wealthy again
we have made america strong again
we have made america proud again
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you arizona get out
and vote
cause you're in a new town there's no
need
to be
and i'm sure you will find many ways
hey
but you've got to know this
one thing no man does it all by himself
it's fun to
boys
ymca they can't stop
it's fun to see it
there's no need
wow
you wanna be
blue
for the band
music man
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always
you